jimmy aka bonus is going to get things
started here for the seattle mariners
made his first outing in an m's uniform
he will be the first one that the ac in
what we believe will be a
parade of relievers out of that mariner
bullpen and right away the a's have
runners on it first and second grossman
checking in swinging a ground ball at
first up with the ball white down to
second for one waltons relay back to
white dead it's not in time and
yakabonus was in the way there jacque
bonus the pitcher was right alongside
evan white i don't think i've ever seen
that before yeah and as a pitcher i
appreciate the effort get over but at
some point in time get out of the way
and now the asap the base is loaded with
the battery is marcano and there's a
base at left field la stella scores
hayes will keep the bases loaded and
they lead one nothing that'll bring up
center fielder ramon loreano swinging a
high flight ball deep left center field
on the run to the winning track kyle
lewis near the wall leaps up and he
makes the catch
holy smokes kyle lewis over the wall and
left center brings it back and he takes
a grand salami away from raymond l'oreal
holy smokes and that will retire the
side what a play
by kyle lewis mike miner making his 10th
appearance ninth start of the season
second start here with the a since
coming over on the deadline and dylan
moore lays it off a right-handed hitter
now this one's driven to left center and
deep but it's playable for laureano he's
there and he makes the catch so here's
ty france here's a fly ball to right
that's playable on cannas coming on he's
right there and he makes the cash so two
up and two down one nothing oakland
bottom of the first and that'll bring up
center fielder kyle lewis south side to
lewis and he walks that'll bring up kyle
sieger the designated hitter for game
two he's swung on lifted high in the air
right field canada going back has a play
on the track comes in a step in front of
the track and he makes the catch and
miner gets through the bottom of the
first runners at first and second one
out now he has to go through the teeth
of the oakland a's order that's right
here comes marcus simeon swung on hit
high in the air left center field kyle
lewis has it tracked in the gap well in
front of the winning track he's there
two on two away and this will bring up
left field to robbie grossman swung on
fly ball into shallow right center field
going out calling for it second baseman
dylan moore is there and the mariners
get themselves out of trouble nice job
by seth frank off the a's have had base
runners all over the place so far and
they have another one here at leadoff
walk in the third and that brings jake
lam up for his second a's at bat and he
swings and sends it to deep right giving
chase's lopes toward the wall can't get
it up the second base with a double is
jake lamb collects his first a's base
hit and oakland threatening again
runners at second and third and just one
away here's lorianno swung on down the
right field line into the corner lopes
giving chase still going can't get it
it's a fair ball he falls down into foul
territory the a's get two loriano drives
in a pair and it's three-nothing oakland
here's heim the catcher swung on and hit
hard to first pass the diving right
that's down into right field for it
loriano's around third rbi single jonah
heim and four-nothing oakland it's gonna
load the bases for marcus simeon and
still only one
away rounded to third
not at second on the first not in time
so marcus beats it out and it helps him
get an rbi and it's five nothing as heim
comes in to score and robbie grossman
steps to the plate he's the only one who
is not hit in the inning for oakland
there's a ground ball through the middle
of the diamond for a base hit machine is
home grossman drives it a run make it
six nothing oakland at second goes
robbie grossman with a stolen base
here's right fielder mark cannon that's
swung on it drilled left field back on
it marmaleo's deep in the alley lewis
from center he will turn and watch it
fly
and kanna has hit it out and the
athletics have taken an 8-nothing lead
and they really get a cushion in this
top of the sixth inning jake lam glam
breaking ball high driving to right
lopes going back love set the track
he'll turn and watch it fly
and welcome to the athletics in a big
way tonight jake lamb and the a's have
taken a nine to nothing lead mike miner
has been outstanding tonight for the a's
and mike miner having his best outing of
the year but without question one has
set out one hit and mike miner trying to
go the distance he has three complete
games in his career two of them last
year they were nine in incomplete games
this does count payoff pitch to ty
france
here it is and he got him swinging
strikeout number eight
mariners are down to their final two
outs and that'll bring up center fielder
kyle lewis swinging a line drive down
the field line it's going to be a fair
ball all the way into the corner and in
its second with the one out double goes
kyle lewis
one on one ounce here's kyle seeger and
the pitch is swung on and that is hit
high in the air foul territory first
base side near the mariners dug out
coming in as seth brown he's going to
give way to
jonah heim who's there to make the play
for the second hour the mariners down to
their final out here in the second game
of the doubleheader this should do it
shallow right center and it's tony kemp
who makes a nice over the shoulder catch
and that's how the ball game comes to an
end and what a ball game it was for mike
miner